so as most of you know I am NOT with Joe
Biden on health care Joe Biden is
starting the negotiation from a very
centrist point which is let's tweak
Obamacare and add a public option we'd
be lucky to get to that if you start the
conversation at the most progressive
point if that's where Joe starts we
won't even get that and I'm not with him
whatsoever I'm not with Joe Biden on
cannabis legalization he's against it
I'm for it
Joe Biden recently said cannabis is a
gateway drug that's been widely debunked
beyond it being a gateway to violence
when it's illegal because people have to
get into situations that are less than
savory in order to get their cannabis
but beyond that it's not a gateway drug
I am well to Joe Biden's left
I'm a Warren Bernie guy but I must tell
you I reviewed Joe Biden's tax plan and
it's like sort of okay in a very mild
way I guess I'm saying it's not terrible
given lots of Joe Biden's other
positions now of course there's no
wealth tax and Biden's plan he told a
group of wealthy donors behind closed
doors that their wealth is basically
safe if he becomes president he won't do
anything to radically change or
challenge their privileged position in
society that's not a surprise but given
how off Joe Biden has been in so many
other areas his tax plan is better than
I would have expected so let's take a
look at it and discuss it let's go
through some are bigger deals than
others first of all taxing capital gains
and dividends as income is huge right
now capital gains taxes max out at 20
percent so if you're a wealthy person
who would pay the top rate on earned
income money you make via dividends and
capital gains is only taxed at 20% if
you tax capital gains and dividends as
ordinary income you will collect
significantly more money from the very
rich who are mostly earning money from
dividends and capital gains Oh
businesses they own stocks they own for
example rather than labor this is a big
deal of course people will find ways to
try to get around it but this is a
really big deal Joe Biden would raise
the corporate tax rate to 28% this is
fine Trump
from 35 to 21 but what's important to
remember is that huge corporations often
don't play it pay anything close to what
the corporate tax rate is anyway because
of loopholes many corporations pay zero
or even get tax credits so I agree that
we should bring the corporate tax rate
back up this is not some miracle and
let's not make it out to be one because
there are lots of ways to get around
paying any corporate tax as it is Joe
Biden would end the stepped-up basis
rule this really benefits the rich the
way this works is if I buy a thousand
dollars worth of stock and I sell it for
ten thousand dollars
I've profited nine thousand dollars you
take the ten thousand you subtract out
my basis which was the thousand bucks I
paid so I pay taxes on the nine thousand
dollar gain stepped-up basis means that
in certain situations for example if
shares are inherited when someone dies
the recipient is able to step up their
cost basis so those same thousand dollar
shares if I inherit them when they are
worth nine thousand dollars and then
sell them for ten thousand dollars I am
able to step up my basis to nine
thousand dollars and now I only pay
taxes on a gain of a thousand between
9,000 and 10,000 rather than that full
gain Biden would get rid of that Biden
would put in place a fifteen percent
corporate minimum tax now this is a good
idea the devil is in the details the
minimum tax suggests that you've got
your official corporate tax rate of
twenty eight percent you can start to
take deductions to lower your effective
tax rate but the minimum tax would say
that no matter what deductions you're
entitled to you can't deduct yourself to
a point where you pay below a fifteen
percent tax rate that's a great idea
the problem is often there are
deductions that are exempted from that
so it's all in the implementation still
a fine idea 21% tax on foreign profits
fine but again a lot of it is how do you
implement it capping deductions for the
wealthy is fine cracking down on tax
havens is a good one but it's vague
there will very often be you know other
countries that enter with other
opportunity
to avoid taxes it's the right idea
implementing it effectively is very
difficult Biden would raise the top tax
rate to thirty nine point six percent
now that's fine that's the top rate we
had under the Obama presidency after the
Bush tax cuts expired again lots of rich
people earn through capital gains and
dividends anyway what I would like to
see are higher marginal tax rates
established for higher levels of income
you know a new tire rate for a million
and above an even higher rate for five
million ten million and above Biden
doesn't do that it's not surprising but
at least he's rolling back the put it
putting the top tax rate back to where
it was under Barack Obama um
Biden would also close real estate
loopholes and and fossil fuel tax breaks
that's fine the devil is in the details
so this is a fine left-of-centre tax
plan it's way better than what we have
it won't do anything about the
military-industrial complex that's a
budgeting thing on the spending side
that's not a revenue thing it doesn't
fix health care that's a separate issue
Joe's plan is very milquetoast centrist
on health care but calling things what
they are it's a tax plan that goes in
the right direction with some good
tweaks it doesn't really shake anything
up
which is exactly what Joe Biden promised
rich people once again I don't agree
with much of his policy but Joe's being
honest he told those rich people nothing
will fundamentally change and challenge
your privileged status in society which
is widely unquestioned at the top
echelon of power he told us that that's
what he would do and that's exactly what
his tax plan would do while doing some
ok things let me know what you think
about this tax plan I know the wealth
tax is missing I know higher tax
brackets at higher income levels are
missing I get all of that let me know
what you think i'm on instagram at david
pakman follow the show on instagram at
david pakman show privacy calm is one of
our sponsors and they're giving you
$5.00 just for using their free service
at privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's
of service I've been using for a while
now I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's complete
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman